scp-066 was once a wholesome
music-loving ball of colorful living
yarn known colloquially as eric's toy
however while this came to the
foundation as a relatively benign and
friendly creature the actions of the
foundation itself soon turned this
anomaly sour during a test a foundation
researcher cut a thread from scp-066
causing it not only considerable pain
and distress but also making it lose all
trust in the foundation it went from
being a happy ball of ribbon that would
change into a friendly form like cats
and produce birthday cupcakes for
researchers to an angry little twisted
knot of wretched flesh-like twine it
seems that scp-066 holds a grudge for
the way it was treated too now it
regularly deafens researchers and guards
in its proximity with loud music in
revenge for its mutilation oh and why do
they call it eric's toy well when it's
not producing ear shattering music to
mess with the researchers and other
anomalous effects it can be heard saying
the name eric in a deep masculine voice
although who this eric is we just don't
know